okay so one of the things that you just
did talk about was the notch count and
virginity
um
i thought it was really interesting to
look back even in my life and other
women that i know like when did they
start having sex and how that impacts
maybe how many partners they have how
they just kind of jump from man to man
because that's what they've done since
they were 14 you know
um why do you think that the virginity
age
impacts that
but
it's it's not a guess or anything it's
based on um science really i mean
because
we know statistically speaking the older
a woman is that she loses her virginity
and the lower the number of male
partners that she's had
the more likely she is to be happy and
want to stay in a long-term marriage
like
a woman that's been with a hundred guys
50 guys 25 guys is much much less likely
to be able to form a pair bond with a
guy than a woman that's a virgin or has
only been with one or two guys and a
woman that lost her virginity at 13 or
14 is less likely to be a good long-term
partner than a woman that lost her
virginity at 23.
um those are facts uh you know
statistically speaking so um i mean like
when i talk to guys like one of the
first questions if i get a guy that's on
the horn and he wants to talk about i'm
not sure about her should i marry her
sort of thing like you know we're
engaged and there's these problems sort
of thing it's like okay what's your
sexual past like right like
like is this really good wife stock
because if she's been with a whole bunch
of guys
and she lost her virginity at a very
young age the chances of you getting
divorced are exceptionally high and what
does that mean
if you have kids you're barely going to
see them generally speaking if you've
got high net worth you're going to lose
a good chunk of it right so why would
you want to put yourself in that risky
you know situation
right and uh the women if they're losing
their virginity at 14 aren't going to
value themselves or anything else you
know they're just going to
just looking back i was raised mormon so
super religious
and like sex wasn't even in the question
until much later but
now i'm like damn maybe that was really
beneficial for me because there was a
value put on virginity there was a value
put on the girls especially like saving
things for marriage
well there's a reason why the prize when
arabs go to
you know the afterlife whatever is 70
virgins and not a mercedes or a ferrari
right
but do you really want 70 virgins i
don't know i don't know oh there's
another thing that you talked about
controlling the birth okay
i'd heard somebody else say it as
like control your sperm like know where
your sperm is going kind of thing
and with my son like that's
i think that's really important women
can be
so manipulative when it comes to
trapping a man with a kid
whether they're like on the pill maybe
they're having a fight with their
boyfriend so they take the wrong pill on
accident and all of a sudden look we're
pregnant and now you have to stick
around forever
um
controlling the birth
is huge and taking control of
your dick i think
yeah
it's it's really just taking ownership
for your sperm because once it leaves
your body you don't have any decision
making capacity whatsoever it all falls
on her
right so again it's like you know why
would you want to risk yourself to that
exposure a lot of what i talk about is
about risk management right inviting the
right kind of woman in your life if you
have you know the right come in your
life or you're dating a woman you know
how are you going to deal with her
sexually
you know how far in your life are
uninvited she can be kept at arm's
length you know and it and it just
doesn't deal with women like i talk to a
lot of guys about money finance and
creating wealth and businesses like i
have a course on building your own
business sort of stuff
so a lot of it is about risk management
right and
and when it comes to controlling the
birth it's like
guys i get it you want to have sex
you're a man you're placed on this earth
to scatter seed we all are here for the
same reason i understand that but if
you're going to go about that in life
make sure you're in control of what
happens to your seed when it leaves your
body
yeah because there's so many
consequences down the line if you don't
fart they're they're far too severe for
a man to be frivolously just
going where he wants with his seat
yeah hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you